all right thanks to everyone for coming
today once again conditions are such
that we are forced to hold our annual
research symposium
online for a second year
uh
sorry about that but i'm glad that all
of you have joined us today
um before we begin uh i think we'd like
to note that
while we are meeting today there is an
active conflict underway where innocent
lives are being lost in israel palestine
many of us and many of you have
relatives and families impacted by this
conflict
the staff of the archive hopes that the
violence will soon cease and we wish
peace for both palestinians and israelis
for those of you who i haven't met
before my name is stephen aaron and i'm
the director of the fortune off video
archive for holocaust testimonies
i'm grateful to all of you for zooming
in from other parts of the country in
the world after a long year of
zoom-based events
this is the archive's fourth research
symposium our fellowship program is
still very young but i hope that you
will agree after seeing the results of
today's symposium that it aims to make a
significant contribution to
international scholarship about and
based upon video testimonies of
holocaust survivors
we established the fortune off archives
fellowship program with the launch of
the hartman fellowship in 2018
where it was conceived as a fitting way
to honor one of the archives founders
its faculty advisor for decades
professor jeffrey hartman who passed
away on march 14 2016.
an eminent professor of comparative
literature at yale jeffrey's vision and
leadership helped build the fortunate
archive into the institution that it is
today
our fellowship program has grown to
include other fellowships all named for
the four founders of the archive
dori lao jeffrey hartman laurel vlogt
and willie rosenberg
four recurring fellowships with
different areas of focus for four
individuals with whom we would not be
here today
beyond our founders there are many other
individuals and organizations to whom i
would like to offer a few words of
thanks this fellowship program would not
be possible without the support of our
faculty advisor timothy snyder professor
doug rogers who's head of your russian
east european and eurasian studies at
yale
and jenny shemasna at the macmillan
center
which is the official institutional home
of all of our fellows at yale
the archive is grateful for all of your
assistance recruiting and shepherding
our international fellows through the
process of becoming part of the yale
community
i would also like to thank our partners
at the vienna wiesental institute in
particular eva kovach for providing the
framework funding and international
support for our joint fellows in vienna
finally i'd like to express my gratitude
to the fortune of
blaustein cole hornos libyan ross
families and dozens of other donors
large and small that help make the
archive possible
the primary goal of the fellowship
program is to encourage scholarship in
the collection and to unlock testimonies
and make them more accessible
as intellectually as well as
accessible to users by by charging our
fellows with the task of producing an
annotated critical edition of a single
testimony from the collection
i'd like to invite our hartman fellow
gil rubin to tell us more about the
critical edition series as well as well
as introduce our speakers today gil
thank you stephen um so i'm just gonna
think just for a few minutes um i'm
going to introduce our critical
additions series that was launched
earlier this year
in february and i'm actually going to
share my screen now
and tell you a little bit about what it
is um
so
every year our
postdoctoral fellows are visiting
scholars um and various other people
associated with the um the archive uh
produce a critical addition
um and uh what crystal critical edition
is and does everybody see the page
currently or
yeah okay what a critical edition is is
basically um every visiting scholar
selects one testimony from our
collection um and then they produce um
two things from it they produce an
introduction which is a text that is
designed for the public for students for
other researchers that places that
testimony in its historical context and
situates it within the contemporary
historical scholarship and literature
that is relevant for it um so we had we
could have about right now we have eight
different um testimonies here um eight
different critical editions um and the
second thing um that it does is it
actually um just the the researcher and
scholar they look at the view um the
testimony and they represent um and they
produce an annotated
transcript that is once you view the
translation online i'm going to show in
a second you can actually see um
explanations of various words places and
so forth that help you kind of
understand that testimony um and
situated in its time and place so i'm
going to look now at just one testimony
at one our critical editions and kind of
guide you through it
so this is this was produced by sarah
garibava who was
one of the hartman fellows here and what
you can see here through this online
viewer is that we have an online display
of um her introduction to the testimony
that presents kind of the the general
historical background but also situates
it with the relevant literature
you can click on the various footnotes
um here and get
kind of either more information or other
sources that are relevant
and this is how it's kind of viewed
online from the landing page to viewing
each and every testimony
and then
if you if you want you can actually hear
their hear songs and testimony
so they will open up and you can
actually listen to
this in this case
the edition she worked on includes a
song that was later reproduced
also
in our song from the testimonies project
and additionally beyond this you can
actually go online and view the
testimony that has opened uh open to
everyone to view i'll just open it here
um and view it together with an
annotated
so you can see over here once there's a
word um
that requires any type of explanation um
so you can see here um you know dr
grifova's explanation on this specific
word on this specific concept on this
specific idea that is presented um in
the annotated scholarship um so the idea
here is actually to take our testimonies
that are often
accessible either in civic language to a
group of researchers or people who speak
the language and bring them to
researchers
who might not work on this specific
subset of testimonies and languages
bring them to students and bring them to
the public
and so far within the critical edition
series we have eight different um
critical editions and we hope to add
more throughout the year and actually
three of the talks um that we are going
to hear um today are um are actually
going to turn into critical editions and
i think the speakers um will present
more about that um i will pre i will add
now to the chat um a link to our
critical edition series and um i'm happy
to answer on any uh happy to answer any
more questions about this but i just
wanted to kind of present here both so
we can celebrate and announce the
publication of the series which um you
know was
the result of a lot of effort of work um
by our scholars um and other people at
the archive um and also kind of give
context into some of the talks that
we'll hear today and see actually how
these critical additions are created and
the type of questions
and issues that the scholars are
grappling with as they produce it
so i'm going to
put it in the chat in a minute but
before we do that i'm just going to
present our first speaker for today
so basically how it's going to work we
have two sessions um
so um
chad gibbs and julie dawson are going to
present first and then we'll have a q a
session and then we will um hear
presentations from wendy lauer and
jonathan metropolis
and i'll just start with a short intro a
short biography of chad
and then i'll give him the floor and let
him speak
uh chad gibbs is a phd candidate at the
university of wisconsin-madison and the
inaugural dory loud fellow at the
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies um and we want to
congratulate him that in the fall of
2021 he will take up the position of
assistant professor of jewish studies
and director of the zucker goldberg
center for holocaust studies at the
college of
charleston um and he works on resistance
at treblinka and his work on the topic
um was supported by fellowships from the
united states austin memorial museum the
usc show up foundation and the georgia
mossad program in history
and today he's going to present about
his work about resistance um in
treblinka and i'll just um give you the
floor and let you present
all right thank you for that
introduction we're seeing my screen okay
all right on the occasion of samuel
willenberg's passing in 2016 media
outlets around the world warned him as
the last treblinka death camp survivor
many outlets ran stories and obituaries
prominently featuring that word last
two days later though the times of
israel corrected itself by running
another story entitled quote there are
still tremendous survivors among us
one tells his tale unquote
having seen earlier reports the daughter
of leon ritz reached out to the press to
tell of her father's experiences
ritz still lives in sweden where he
settled not long after world war ii
he's well known there but his story
hadn't come to the attention of press
outside of sweden
after the times and other outlets wrote
about ritz though a new framing of
survival at treblinka began to take hold
the time subsequently relabeled
willenberg the final survivor of the
august 1943 treblinka prisoners revolt
with italic emphasis
leon ritz as he explained to amanda
borschel don of the times escaped
treblinka before the now famous august
2nd 1943 revolt
ritz also survived several other camps
these facts led borschel done
questioning left her questioning how we
should
label his experiences
she wondered whether
it was factually correct to call ritz a
treblinka survivor because he was also
imprisoned at majdanek buchenwald and
bergen-belsen
borschel dhan took her question to yad
vashem's efudemir
who assured her that there is quote no
binding definition of how a holocaust
survivor is labeled a person who is in
several camps can be considered a
survivor from each camp in which they
were a prisoner unquote
the passing of samuel goldenberg and the
late recognition of leon ritz opened new
conversations in the media
noting as they did the different kinds
of survival stories told by willenberg
and ritz media outlets began to qualify
different versions of survival at
treblinka willenberg became the last
treblinka revolt survivor while ritz
holds center stage as the last living
survival
and
a pre-revolt escapee
amir's explanation highlights the fact
that there's no commonly understood way
to label holocaust survivor experiences
and in addition to this at present
there's no historiography of the term
survivor
as it relates to a specific place like a
camp ghetto or shooting site
many historians and organizations offer
capacious and respectful definitions of
the wider term holocaust survivor but i
don't think we have looked at how the
term survivor can be employed locally
and what that might do for research
i think that lack of place specific
understandings of survival is
particularly noteworthy
with the vibrant expansion of spatial
holocaust research
but as they reacted to the passing of
willenberg and the late emergence of
ritz reporters began an explanation of
these questions and what their answers
might mean for understandings of the
holocaust
a revisitation of survival at treblinka
offers opportunities to analyze what it
means to be a survivor of a certain
place during the holocaust as well as a
chance to assess how many jews made it
out of this extermination camp and how
they did so
defining survivorship for individual
holocaust locations like the thousands
of camps and ghettos of the nazi system
is an essential step for historians
seeking to clarify the roles uses and
evolutions of those sites
at treblinka the varied means of
survival represented by people like
willenberg and ritz also point to a need
for like some basic categories of
survivor experience
research that defines survival of
certain places can for instance help
scholars understand the reach and
influence of a site beyond its seemingly
discreet fences walls
or
borders like that
my own interest in survival at treblinka
and finding out how many people survive
this place comes from
my works
need to deal with a
well-accepted number of survivors at
trilinka
um many in this audience and other
panelists here might
might know the number 68 that might jump
out at them as the
accepted number of survivors at
treblinka and that number comes from the
1979 book the death camp treblinka um an
edited volume by a man named alexander
danat who was himself a
holocaust survivor and had been in the
warsaw ghetto
he listed 68 people that he was able to
find in the process of his research in
the mid 70s
and though he said at the time
that
that list was anything but uh i think
his exact words were are
anything but exhaustive uh it's pretty
much gained a canonical acceptance
um when i begin talking about my work at
a conference or something like that i
usually get the question how do you do
work on treblinka there are only 68
survivors it happens
quite a bit it's a very well accepted
number
but i have looked at this matter of how
many people survived treblinka and come
now
to after a lot of archival work
throughout my dissertation research come
to
251 named or identified survivors of the
camp
and come up with three main ways in
which they survive treblinka so of those
251 people
71 are revolt survivors like isidore h
from the fortune of archive
and that category kind of it seems to
jump out as the most easy to explain
category of survival experience at
treblinka but it gets
it gets somewhat murky
and it is instructive for finding the
boundaries of the camp
so isidore h escaped treblinka on um
august 2nd 1943 during that that
prisoner revolt uh he took part in the
revolt but if i'm looking at whether or
not to put a person in that category i
don't require that they took part or
even knew that
resistance was going to take place that
day for me it's enough that
they saw the revolt taking place and
wisely made for the fences as everyone
else did
where the category gets instructive
about the limits of treblinka local
power
is in looking at
the so about 300 people made it out
during the revolt but we've only
identified 71 of those individuals
many lost their lives in in the chase
away from treblinka or
um where perhaps some were caught by
locals um and brought back to the camp
in in search of in hope of a reward
um so on and so forth so in looking at
how far they got away from the camp
um after how much time they were brought
back i i believe that in that we can
kind of see the local power
of treblinka and its and its
perpetrators
the uh second
group of individuals that i look at in a
larger group that is that i look at is
escapees
and to disambiguate that term i mean
anyone who escaped treblinka on a day
other than august 2nd 1943 it's
uh to my knowledge it is only um these
74 people are only individuals who
escaped before the revolt
so sometimes they escaped in
um
random acts uh unplanned acts i should
say uh and sometimes they escaped in
kind of
smaller scale
uh networked
um pre-planned events where they and i
think the largest i've seen is about
nine others got out at the same time by
coming up with and planning a means to
escape the camp
um and what they do and what looking at
this category and its uh
and its timeline especially because
there's a certain date at which about
january of 1943
um at which escape from treblinka really
comes to an end this
option of resistance this option of
trying to survive the camp kind of stops
being viable
um and that is because there had been so
many escapes you'll notice that number
is just
it's pretty large i believe for a camp
that only operated for 11 months and um
larger than our previous knowledge of
how many people who survived at all
and in that
i it instructs as to how big of a
problem
escape was for the nazi guards who ran
treblinka so much so that in january of
43 they opened a new barracks building
that basically cut off this version of
this of survival but at the same time
um that was something of a putting out a
bonfire by starting a forest fire
because once they moved all treblinka
prisoners to that new barracks
prisoner uh testimonies then start to
say well now we could plan a revolt
because we could all talk to each other
in the barracks at night so that was a
pivotal turning point
in treblinka history brought about by
this form of resistance by escapes prior
to the revolt
and finally there's one last major
category that i want to cover
perhaps i'll have to leave some of it
for q a if we want to get there
but i call this last group through
transport survivors and this sort of
changes
our understanding of how the nazis used
treblinka as a part of the wider
holocaust
because the certain timing of people who
were brought to treblinka stepped off
the train
and were then put back on a train to
somewhere else tells us about the camp's
role
in wider perpetration so ben l here
um who was incredibly
shocking for me to find because it
turned out that ben l
uh his his family is actually uh third
generation wisconsin badgers so i ended
up finding out that a current undergrad
at my own university is a descendant of
of this man
[Music]
and these people came in about two
different ways they came as the warsaw
ghetto uprising was taking place and
they also came
as a
resistance was going on in the bialystok
ghetto
and
in a longer explanation i could get into
how that really informs us about
treblinka's how treblinka fit into these
other events and how those other events
changed what went on at treblinka
that being my last major case if you've
been following along quickly with your
calculator or something you'll notice
that the numbers don't entirely add up
and that's because there are some
individuals there their their story
doesn't exactly give us enough
information to
uh
to say for certain how they survived
and there are a few very unique cases um
but i couldn't get into those in the
amount of time here
so
um just to to wrap up
uh leon ritz the media's quote last
survivor of treblinka
may well be the last living voice of
survivor at survival at this
extermination camp
though it's impossible to know for
certain i think that's the most
important thing to point out about any
making of a list the fact that a
treblinka survivor would now be nearing
100 years old makes it likely that mr
ritz is alone in his experiences
similarly the increasing age of all but
the youngest child survivors of the
holocaust means that these last
experience and last voice news stories i
think will sadly only increase in the
coming years
as they do
journalists like the times borshle don
will struggle to find prudent and
respectful ways to describe the lives
and paths of the people they cover
historians i think would be would do
well to get ahead of this coming wave of
media definitions by providing their own
this however is not the only reason that
scholars should address the definition
of survivorship at the places they study
research on treblinka demonstrates that
we should be prepared to find another
kind of last survivor of the camp many
individuals
now passed away remain unacknowledged
survivors of this place
the permanently incomplete nature of any
survivor list means that even after mr
ritz leaves us
others who survive will still await
recognition
defining place specific survival can
advance our understandings of localized
perpetration the actions of victims in
context and the spatial reach of
individual sites of holocaust
criminality
revolt survivors compel us to consider
where the bounds of this camp stopped
complicating any simplistic view of the
fences
as its bounds of perpetrator power
escape survivors meanwhile provide an
important understanding of how jewish
resistance changed the very face of
treblinka and helped create the
conditions needed for revolt planning
through transport survivors take us take
our knowledge of resistance other than
revolt still further
while also allowing us to see how
treblinka fit into the wider holocaust
as well as how camp routines change over
time
i don't propose a single definition of
place-based survivorship i think that
many of the over 44 000 camps and
ghettos of the third reich will require
unique understandings
the thousands of mass shooting sites may
demand still more reckonings with the
idea of survivorship
localized definitions though will help
scholars seeking to understand the
experiences choices and paths of the
individuals they study who were forced
to confront nazi genocide
spatial studies of the holocaust will
benefit still further from this means of
determining the boundaries of their
studies and how they fit into overall
trends
finally the uh the active idea of
defining survival in a capacious and
respectful manner makes it possible to
honor the stories of the people that we
study
increasing the number of survivors of a
place like treblinka that killed as many
as 925 000 people
from 68 to 251 in no way alters its
overwhelming lethality
the importance of my work for the
history of treblinka is instead the
creation of an update to denotes list
that's more capable of foregrounding
the differences in individual paths to
survival and demonstrating to interested
researchers that additional testimonial
evidence awaits their use
um the stories of those left off to
not's list deserve recognition and
inclusion by future scholars even while
we continue to acknowledge that no list
will ever be complete
thank you
i'll stop sharing now
thank you chad um thank you so much
for your talk i'll just
remind everyone that you can leave
questions in the q a and that will take
them after chad's talk it was wonderful
talk and super um super interesting i
think it's going to tie to some of the
other things we're going to hear today
um did somebody raise his hand um
jonathan
i i did raise my hand at least virtually
um thank you chad for an excellent talk
very interesting i wanted to ask you
about the uh through transport survivors
um i confess i had not heard about
people arriving at treblinka and then
diverted and sent elsewhere because
could you elaborate and tell us a bit
more about what the purpose was and what
the experience was like for those
through transport survivors thanks thank
you um i think so there's two
two more prevalent experiences among
that group
uh number one is that individuals would
arrive at treblinka sometimes and the
train would stop at treblinka two the
extermination camp
and then at times the labor needs of
treblinka one the nearby uh labor and
penal camp which
is often said to have been four polish
prisoners but had a large jewish
population as well sometimes that camp's
needs if we want to put it that way
would be
met by taking people off of a train at
treblinka 2 and putting them back on
sorting them if you want and putting
them back on a train to treblinka one
and we learn about resistance in this
moment
even if it's a very short period of time
because a lot of stories are told about
how how people tried to look ready for
work
how they tried to jump into a line if
they saw that you know this is the right
line to be in so there's a lot of very
quick thinking resistance that's like
short episodes but very important and
saves many lives
um that other
group
is usually sent on to my donek so
at the time of the warsaw ghetto
uprising particularly i'll just simplify
things by staying on that one topic
with this answer
at the time of the warsaw ghetto
uprising it seems that um the nazis
tried to push
the population of the warsaw ghetto out
on trains as fast as they possibly could
and that meant that they didn't sort
probably in the way that they normally
did
and people were instead sorted at
treblinka and then those thought fit for
labor will were placed back on the train
and sent to lublin mydonic
um so that
that experience happens at basically two
different times it's kind of the same
episode the same
reasoning going on but it occurs at the
time of the warsaw ghetto uprising and
at the time of resistance in the
bialystok ghetto as that is being closed
excellent excellent um thank you very
very helpful um out of curiosity what
was the survival rate at my donek for
the people who were sent on there um
probably very very low as well i i would
presume right
it's it's yeah so it's it's very it's
low it's not good however it's um
it's way better
it you know it's way better than if they
had stayed at treblinka where there's
basically other than the revolt
um once you're in the camp
if you can't get out in the revolt or
you can't escape on your own it's almost
certain death
being sent on to mydonic
after you've already been chosen
quote unquote fit for work
the the chances of survival are
much much better than had you not stayed
or than had you stayed at treblinka so
it's
um
a lot of those people do
lose their lives later um either through
being worked um
[Music]
worked far too hard at wherever they
were sent next
um but i you know i didn't actually say
in the talk that i i count someone as a
treblinka survivor even if they die
later in the holocaust i know of many
individuals who fit um
that explanation
um but i think that we need to keep them
there because they you know it doesn't
change the the one event in their life
to have
perished in another incident
um but yeah
it's still bad uh just to sum up but um
so much better than than staying at
triple income
thank you excellent
thank you um i think with the rest of
the questions that seem there's another
question from professor minon pod um but
we'll take them i think after julie's um
presentation just we um kind of take the
questions again that's fine i mean i i
could have read that again but um so
i'll just um present um julie briefly
and then after julie's presentation um
we're going to have a q a session um
with both julie and chad
julie dawson is the um fortunate fellow
at the vienna byzantine institute
and a doctoral candidate at the
university of vienna's institute for
contemporary history her dissertation
examines post-war jewish life in romania
through the lengths of recently found
diaries of trans transnistrian survivors
she worked for the leo beck institute
from 2010 to 2019 and directed their
archival survey of transylvania and
bukovina from 2012 to 2019 um and she
was a researcher um in madison romania
for the uri eu horizon 2020 project
called traces transmitting contentious
cultural heritage with the arts um and
she's published several articles um
which you can see um on our um website
on our on her bio and our website and
her research more generally includes um
jewish pocovina communist romania
women's history trauma and memory
studies um and i'll let you start uh
presenting julie um and please write any
other questions you have for either
julian chad in the q a session and we
will discuss them uh briefly
all right thank you very much gail and
steven and the fortunate archive for the
invitation and support
um my project is
somewhat different from the other
presentations as my focus is not on oral
histories per se but rather on this
newly discovered written testimony that
gill mentioned a set of diaries written
in the media post-war period in romania
uh due to the nature of the diaries
however consulting oral histories is
crucial for contextualizing my subject's
holocaust experience and that i use oral
histories to complement and expand my
subjects writings
i'm also only a little halfway through
my fellowship i took maternity leave
part way through so my research is still
ongoing um i view new material every
week every day and gain new insights all
the time
in this short talk i'm going to
introduce my overall project with the
diaries is the core analytic lens i'll
give some biographical background on the
author i'll dip just a tiny bit into
trauma theory and discuss my continuing
examination of the associated oral
histories
so
diary one spring day in 2009 a
peach-colored notebook was discovered by
volunteers cleaning up a
document-littered women's balcony of a
shuttered synagogue in a small
transylvanian town
the notebook it quickly became clear was
a diary filled from cover to cover with
carefully penciled german the words very
clear to read and often distressed
eventually four notebooks and several
related papers were found
containing over 800 entries the diaries
stretched from 1948 to 1961
and record the post-war life of brief
and limited triumph of a young survivor
of the transnistrian holocaust blanca
laid celta
these diaries are a tremendous tool for
researchers they provide multi-faceted
entry points for examining daily life of
jewish survivors in the initial decades
after the war
as well as for analyzing the
repercussions of violent trauma to
everyday life
they indicate spaces in which
individuals were able to perform acts of
agency despite totalitarian strictures
and also those places where the cold
machinations of the totalitarian state
devastated individual lives
they moreover shed light on cultural and
social practices and jewish life at the
time with especially fascinating
insights into the operations of romanian
zionist youth organizations in the late
1940s about which little to nothing has
been written to date
furthermore as an inherently gendered
source the writings testify to the life
of a young single woman
raised at the interface of tradition and
modernity struggling for a voice in a
profoundly patriarchal nation
finally the author's narration of global
events from the founding of the state of
israel to the 1956 hungarian uprising
as well as a political and cultural
responses to the holocaust such as the
establishment of german reparations and
the publication of anna frank's diaries
indicate an interconnectedness to the
world that belies and assumed
impermeability the iron curtain
so
who was blanca laid sultan blanca laid
celta was born near or in chinavex in
the early mid early to mid 1920s
her father joseph laid zelda was a civil
servant during the austro-hungarian
period
fulfilling official clerical duties in
several bukurbinen villages and towns
her mother anna grew up in chernovitz
and her family overlapped with the
social surface of paul ancho later the
poet child
late selter's first cousin gustav was
gustav homed was close boyhead friends
with anchil and in post-war
correspondence the two wrote
nostalgically of gustav's home in the
top vegas
this being also the home of blade
silver's grandparents
and aunt and uncle
the late celta family were entrenched
german-speaking central european jews
her older brother had recently graduated
from the university of prague and
architecture her fiance had studied
medicine there
her father most recently secretary of
the vachekov's town hall was in his 60s
at the start of the war living in quiet
retirement in a home with a garden full
of fruit trees and a small riverside
town a short train ride from chanavits
the lake shelters were generally
assimilated and marginally religious
probably in the inferred manner
explained in one testimony from pearl
powell of chanavits
who when asked about her family's
religious observance and education the
mirrors but when asked specifically
whether her mother lit candles on friday
evenings answers oh definitely yes yes
when the war broke out labe celta was
probably 19 or 20 she was well educated
speaking besides her german mother
tongue romanian russian and english most
likely she understood the edition
ukrainian
she had a deep appreciation for theater
literature and the arts a distinct
distinct from manual labor and was
deeply ashamed of depending on charity
in the summer of 1941 after the
barbarossa operation began the romanian
army invaded northern bukovina which had
been occupied by the soviet union the
previous year
during the first few weeks of july 1941
pogroms were carried out in countless
villages in this region perpetrators
included romanian soldiers ukrainian and
romanian peasants as well as a german
einstein's troop
in lake celta's home of bosch counts the
jews were pulled from their houses and
gathered at the jean da marie
a group of prominent men were selected
for execution marched to a low hill site
outside the town and shot among these
were laid shelter's father and brother
yosef and bruno her fiancee she learns
was similarly murdered in a different
location
late shelter and her mother anna
were later deported to transnistria
where they spent three years in the
moghilav ghetto
upon their release in 1945 the women
returned initially to chernovitz
regarding this homecoming late shelter
rights quote the hour arrived where we
saw appear in the distance the powers of
the channel of its archbishop's
residence i gazed spell bound upon these
towers and listened inside for an echo
of joy
but there was nothing of the kind i
sensed only my raw sore heart and
worries about the future and
she goes on to explain the motives for
their subsequent departure quote we felt
poorly in the old home upon the ruins of
our lives played day and night by the
most horrid memories and among those who
are not innocent in our tragedy end
quote
the two women left making their way
eventually to the black seaport town of
constanza
here the diaries begin in january of
1948 and until 1961 when she finally
received her long for exit visa labe
celta kept record of her daily life and
struggled with loneliness her mother's
eventual death from tuberculosis in 1952
and always a penetrating grief
when she left in 1961 she passed the
diaries to her cousin babette gomez
gustav's sister who had settled after
war in mediash
town transylvania
her last recorded words are quote i am
very exhausted
the moment approaches to leave the old
home and seek a new one what will i find
one is not allowed to bring diaries i
cannot bring myself to destroy them i am
entrusting them to someone for
safekeeping
will they ever find their way back to me
and hope
these diaries were found in 2009 by
volunteers cleaning up the women's
balcony of the synagogue in the
transylvanian town where laid shelter's
cousin had remained almost until her
death in the late 1980s
my project examines these diaries from
multiple perspectives is a singular
testimony representing survivor
narratives that have been little probed
and as a source allowing unexplored
insights
into social and cultural history
considerations of post-war romania my
overarching research questions sent
around trauma oppression and agency my
current focus at the vienna visa intel
institute and working with the fortunate
archive is reconstructing the shelters
wartime experience or context while also
deconstructing the manifestations of
trauma in her post-war writings
in her seminal work on trauma and
narrative
comparative literature scholar kathy
cavu describes the double telling of the
center of trauma narratives she writes
of the quote oscillation between a
crisis of death and the correlative
crisis of life
between the story of the unbearable
nature of an event and the story of the
unbearable nature of its survival
end quote
the diaries witnessed this crisis of
life but understanding late shelter's
crisis of death is essential to
presenting her story
my work with the oral histories of the
fortune fortunate archive aims to fill
this lacuna in lake shelter's biography
even though such a contextualization
will and must be in its very nature
imperfect and incomplete
so how am i incorporating these oral
histories into late selter's story
um she herself mentions transnistria and
the diaries only a handful of times
generally when some aspect of her life
recalls
to her mind her experience for example
when she and her mother are suffering
from severe hunger or without heat when
her hakshara group is thrown out of its
lodgings and made to stand outside in
the snowy night
when state bureaucracy intrudes with
irrational demands
fine details about the pogrom during
which her father and brother were
executed are recalled in three letters
she wrote to the dead
but regarding the years in the mobile
ghetto she writes only a handful of
nondescript sentences
their survival she explains and apparent
disbelief was quote a miracle i cannot
explain it in any other way
for my research i'm looking at all the
interviews of individuals with
overlapping biographical details
especially those who spent time in
mobile
remarkably little has been written about
this site and so i'm looking at anyone
who's there or passed through
the number of individuals who actually
remained in mobylev is small it was a
transit point and many arrived only to
leave within a few days
some who escaped from camps further east
made their way back to mobilev but
generally tried to hide outside of the
ghetto the draw may have been due to the
size of the town and the resulting
anonymity possible food may have been
easier to come by
work which resulted in food may also
have been easier to obtain
ideally of course i would find an oral
history from a woman of similar age and
background to lape shelter who also
spent years in the mughal ghetto thus
far i've not found such an interview
the women in fact tend to be
significantly younger than blanca yes
they were children or adolescents during
the war
these
people experience in addition to the
specific acts of violence the particular
anguish of losing their innocence
learning that their parents could not
protect them or their siblings
the other women tend to be older than
blanca and already with children of
their own the survival or not of their
children generally forms the core of
these women's stories
the men
who are in the ghetto speak of surviving
through work it is not clear if women
were able to work in the same manner as
the men
if not than how their survival was
achieved
as i mentioned i'm only just halfway
through my fellowship and i still have
many interviews to listen to look
forward to my ongoing work and
especially to writing about my results
to conclude i would like to quote
scholars mariana hirsch and leo
schwitzer
in a reflection on creating channels for
silenced or neglected voices of the
transnistrian holocaust they remind us
that quote each individual's story helps
to shape a larger history by providing
it with detailed depth and nuance and in
turn each story is enhanced and given
broader meaning through its
contextualization within a larger
historical matrix
close generations haunted by stories
that have not been worked through
still find that they owe the victims
this act of attentive listening as well
as this act of historical work of
historical repair unquote
so in that note i want to thank the
fortunate archive of the vienna wizanta
institute for enabling this act of
attentive listening and returning a
voice to a subject who is unable to
publicly witness during her lifetime
thank you julie um
thank you for the this wonderful talk i
think we'll open um us up for um some
questions uh feel free um
to write questions um
for um julian chad now in the q a box
and we'll read them out i think we have
a few questions uh for chad that people
wrote um during your presentation um so
i'm gonna read them um out i'm gonna
just read out start with the first two
questions although i think the second
and the third one um
tied together so shouldn't you have the
questions for chad and give an
opportunity to answer them and julie if
you have something to add to that too
please feel free uh to jump in um
so um
chad if you want to also turn on your
video and audio um so you can um
add to that um
pot asks what does your research suggest
about knowledge of the final solution
among jews and poland during the war to
your subjects particularly skps escapees
talk about encountering a refusal to
believe the reports about triple income
um and gabrielle finder asks um what
would you consider polish jews who spent
the war years and the holocaust in
soviet asia would you consider them also
as survivors if they kind of stayed with
an ontario the soviet union um and then
we have another uh question um from owen
steyer um
so you're um you're evolving a critical
definition of survivorship um your brief
remarks at the end about category about
categorizing through transport tripling
to survivors even if they subsequently
perish or murdered another cram
astronomical survivors has the potential
to shake up the very notion of survival
what we do not typically classify
survivors those those individuals who
made it through one or a series of camps
only to be murdered at the last one so
what
will this different perspective do to
understanding of survivorship related to
concepts like resistance um i think all
a lot of these questions um tied
together and uh chad please please
please feel free to answer
yeah um thanks for all these questions
and um thank julie for her excellent
talk as well um
[Music]
i think i'll take the first
part i'm looking at the q a here
there so for escapees part and what they
encounter
about refusal to believe the reports
about treblinka absolutely there's
there's a great deal of that in in oral
histories and other testimonies
um
it took
more than a few the first you know
there's a the first wave of escapees
were not
believed
or were silenced because the
the reality of what they were saying was
too hard
um
for people to bear
but as
as time goes on the partly through how
many people escaped the camp and how
many voices there were saying what it
really was um that information does get
out and it becomes more and more
accepted
and um
testimony from
revolt survivors particularly
individuals who were there for more a
longer period in the camp they talk
about
later transports from poland polish jews
arriving at treblinka
acting out in in spontaneous acts of
resistance as they get off the train
because they know exactly what treblinka
is
um they there's the people have heard
about how the the arrival area treblinka
is painted to look like a train station
and that really that ruse really only
worked on individuals arriving from
western europe
um there were
jews sent to treblinka from 11 different
nations
those from poland tended to already know
what it was and there was a good deal of
resistance in one form or another as
they got off the train
those from western europe or from
further away
tended not to know what treblinka was
and
perhaps that painting of the arrival
area as
um
as a as a train station actually worked
in that way
um so the other two questions i do think
um to dr fender i do think that um
jews who lived out the the holocaust
years in soviet asia are survivors i
particular i personally like
the very very capacious
uh definition of survival that's offered
by the united states holocaust memorial
museum
um that
says that anyone who um fled persecution
basically from
the nazi rise to power in 1933 however
they get out wherever they go is a
holocaust survivor and then to dr
steyer's question that's sort of
connected to that
um
i would say that
i i see where you're asking that and i
think in the longer piece i talk about
how that that individual is still not a
survivor of the holocaust that person
who dies after getting out of treblinka
but they have survival experiences
in their past
um they're
all of these people are victims of the
holocaust
to be sure
so that that terminology doesn't really
help us either but to say that
someone who perishes at their last camp
i would still say they're not a
holocaust survivor because they perished
um
but they can be they can have a past
that is
as a survival survivor of treblinka or
fill in other experience here so i think
that that just kind of
you know maybe it adds a backstory
looking at it in that localized context
as you're bringing up there it adds a
backstory to individuals that we were
only thinking of as as people who
perished on the holocaust perhaps
but
at some at you know at another level
they have survived other things
whatever those might have been
and thanks for all those questions
um thank you chad and i think um joanne
here um grant rudolph writes that
fortune of defined survivors as anyone
who lived under nazi occupation
um that's another edition um i had a
question for julie um also um
here and um my question was a little bit
if you could just expand a little bit
about right because you know the
fortunate market we have video
testimonies and you're also kind of
incorporating that with diaries um maybe
just also you know both specifically
about your research but also generally
working with these two different forms
of um
of historical documentation um right
where do you see the differences what do
you see and what your perspective
working a book with diaries and with um
video testimony what is the difference
and how differently do you think you
approach and we should approach these
types of testimony
yeah thank you um
it's a question i think about a lot um
in particular with these diaries because
they were found diaries and
there are other diaries and of course
memoirs
about transnistria and even that take
place in romania and some of the
post-war time
um but they've been curated and redacted
and um
what
for me is particularly unique about this
source is um
it's lostness i mean the fact that
um
actually we also don't know what
happened to the woman i haven't been
able to find her yet as the project
proceeds i used to think that uh
well i'm not going to focus on that
because i have so many of the things i
need to focus on but as it goes on i'm
finding that
it seems very important to find out what
happened to her afterwards how if
there's any way of finding out what
happened to her and also how she views
this period that i'm writing about
because a lot of these oral histories
are um you know they're
they are told
sort of from a point of view of a happy
ending even though many of the people
are traumatized for life and maybe they
wouldn't
that goes into the whole trauma thing if
you can have a happy ending after what
was experienced
but
but nevertheless
um the memoirs and oral histories talk
about that a lot how did you survive
what did what helped you do this how did
why were you resilient these words and
um
you know this is what we don't have from
the from the diaries we don't know if
she ever
what did she consider than that chapter
of her life just one chapter and she put
it away and she moved on was she able to
move move on in some way
um
i don't know and to me that is the
biggest difference between these diaries
specifically
and and the letters also i didn't go
into the letters but the letters
contained the biographical information
that i provided she writes them to her
deceased loved ones
and
they are narrative and form
and
[Music]
they uh are different they're
more similar to the oral histories in
that sense except for that she did not
write them to an audit or to what
audience did she write them
so i don't know i could talk on and on
about this it's actually an entire
section of my project about sort of what
was the why did she write for whom was
she writing i mean she wanted the
diaries to be kept
um she finds out about ana frank in the
50s and is very moved by this so i think
about that sometimes but of course she'd
already been keeping the diaries for a
long time
but she's extremely moved by um
by the knowledge of that and she in
general was a writer she wrote a screen
book and tried to have it as a um
screenplay
and tried to have it published and
so
yeah these are all questions that i'm
dealing with thank you
thank you um if anyone has it thank you
so much for asking if anyone has any
other questions let me know if not we're
just going to um
um actually move forward onto our next
presentation um by uh professor uh wendy
lauer uh let's shortly present um
christopher um
wendy lauer is the john k roth professor
of history and director of the center
for human rights at claremont makina
mckenna college
lara chairs the academics committee of
the united states holocaust memorial
museum and serves as acting director of
the jack joseph and morton mendel center
for advanced holocaust studies of the
united states holocaust memorial museum
between she served between 2016-2018
and um
she
was a german research foundation fellow
at ludwig maximilian university in
munich
between 2007 2012 uh where she
introduced courses on the holocaust
testimonies of perpetrators and
bystanders and led an initiative to
establish a federally funded german
center for holocaust studies at the
institute for contemporary history um
and uh professor lowry is the author of
multiple books which you can see uh
listed on our profile on our website um
among them the most recent one is uh the
ravine a family a photograph of hawthos
massacre revealed which he also
presented about at yale um i think about
a month ago
and i'm sure many of you have seen also
the reviews um
in the press um and i'll just um let um
professor lauer um
start presenting
thank you so much gil um can you hear me
and see the screen yes okay great well i
want to thank everybody on the team at
the fortune of archive and our host
stephen naren the macmillan center it's
been a real honor
to be the william rosenberg scholar this
semester um
and i just uh you know despite the
limitations with kovid we really enjoyed
our time in new haven and our visits to
the the library and our mining of the
archives there and um just incredibly
grateful for that and i hope that we can
return at some point and do some more of
this in person so let me just get right
down to my presentation um i'm basically
broken down into kind of seven sections
don't be i'm gonna
keep to my time
but the way i've organized it is
basically to start with um eric hauser
is the testimony i'm focusing on his bio
his biography
then
why i selected him and my kind of
selection process and my research
process how i handled this uh source and
his testimony
and then delve into the content of his
presentation why he
testified i mean he dates so explicitly
and i listened to that and and studied
you know what his rationale was and what
stories he wanted to emphasize
um and then um further uh in the
subsequent sections of
to look at some of the ideas that
lawrence langer has presented um
as like frozen moments of anguish as he
puts it um memory of
of the senses these were some of the
elements of this testimony to me that
that popped out that stood out that i
wanted to
delve into
and then lastly um the material culture
part of this or the performative part of
this how he presents things during his
testimony the objects he decides to
bring
into his story and the documents that he
shares um and then it's some concluding
questions about the challenge of as a
historian of annotating and
contextualizing and
what we mean by contextualization and
the limits of that is as well as the
potential problems with over
contextualizing um and kind of
de-centering um
the the survivor's uh testimony um as a
result so i'm kind of grappling with
that balancing
as well as ethical um
endeavor
as an historian
okay let me just tell you a little bit
about eric hauser here he is my
screenshot of him from the
testimony that he he gave um he was born
in 1908 in um grodeck grodk jagalonsky
poland which is now horodoc ukraine he
had two siblings younger siblings a
sister and a brother
grodek's gentile population at the time
of his youth barred jews from entering
the trade gills and as a result the
jewish community there was rather poor
but despite this isaac's family was well
off his father moses was a contractor
with his own business and he built a lot
of houses and issued mortgages to other
jewish families
and isaac's grandfather i'm referring to
isaac
now um
you know interchanging that with eric he
took the kind of american name eric um
when he came arrived in america in 1949
so i will refer to him interchangeably
as isaac and eric so i hope that's not
that confusing
so um isaac's grandfather was the head
of the jewish community and he was able
to use his influence to place
isaac in the catholic high school where
he graduated valedictorian in 1926
um and the community itself from grodeck
prioritized education most could read
polish and german and everyone read
religious texts and like other jewish
youth isaac had leftists in socialist
leanings under polish rule
as a jew isaac was not accepted to a
polish university he moved to
czechoslovakia to attend the technical
university in bruno and in 1931 he got a
master's degree in electrical and
mechanical engineering this is going to
be really important as far as his
ability to survive that education
after completing his studies at the
university he returned to poland his
degree was not recognized by the
authorities he needed to take another
exam this is something he delves into in
his presentation
he worked as an engineer and assistant
manager for a jewish-owned oil field in
western galicia
and in 1939
his family moved into a large house in
la valve they moved into the city
um of laval aviv
the view
poland
um
in september 39 with the start of the
war
um in accordance with the molotov ribbon
toronto pact germany invaded western
poland the soviet army and next eastern
poland
lev was occupied in incorporated into
the ukrainian soviet socialist republic
now part of the russian-dominated soviet
union no more into work no longer into
where poland with the break of the
destruction of poland
so isaac's um a manager at this moment
emptied most of the company's bank
account and fled for america
leaving isaac in charge of 220 employees
and no payroll
his reputation among the employees
prevented them from turning on him
shortly thereafter as the germans
approached isaac was given orders to
dismantle the oil wells and equipment to
make them non-functional
and he goes into a lot of detail his
testimony about
the plants the oil fields um in borislav
and you know he's really impressed with
these these uh the industrial um
materials there and the the kind of
modern features of those plants um
but he still he still kind of reminisces
about that and his eyes light up when he
talks about it so what when they're
dismantling these oil wells and they're
hiding carburetors and trying to make
them non-functional this kind of
sabotage to him i think is kind of is
kind of painful but necessary um during
the night he took four other jews and
they tried to escape in a car
um that he had hidden nearby he was very
clever
um and he they but he was driving on
some dark rough roads and he ended up
crashing the car into a river
um they survived um and his this group
that with the four other jews they
managed to walk to the railroad station
uh they made it to um
caught a train
to levolve and the description there of
the railroad station is really memorable
as well of the german stukas um strafing
and coming down and shooting
deliberately shooting into the windows
of the
railway cars and killing um civilians
and and that was the train they had to
board and um take to live off
um there when he got to live off uh he
met and married louise finkler um so he
would be with his wife throughout the
war um and survived with her um he
couldn't find work in lavabre so he and
his wife louise headed 47 miles south to
boroslav
where he had extended family and he
became the head of a mechanical and
electrical department at the borisov
power plant and works there it's ahead
of a workshop and louise worked there as
well
they were among 13 000 views of boroslav
and subjected to severe restrictions and
psychological abuse by the soviets
in june 41 when germany invaded the
soviet union and occupied borislav a
ukrainian militia organized a violent
pogrom against the jewish population
um here's the location here to give you
a little bit of a geographic orientation
this is from thomas on cooler's book on
the end losing in galician
um here we have the city of lemberg
level
um
groduck here this is where he was born
and grew up isaac
um and he's making his way down here to
the oil fields of petroleum fields of
burislav
not far from
jerojovich
the ukrainian militia organized a
violent program against the jewish
population
and the administration german
administration soon authorized the
establishment of a jewish ghetto in
boroslaug near the end of november
when they conducted their first
organized action in the city capturing
and killing seven to eight hundred jews
thirty members of isaac's extended
family were killed as a result
these actions against the population
continued to take place every few months
and even though they had papers um isaac
had papers that they were that were
supposed to protect them
they still hid during the actions to
avoid getting picked off
on the streets in 1942 ukrainian
amounted german police surrounded
his column marching to work and isaac
fled jumping over a fence of an oral
storage facility while being shot at
during another early action he and his
wife went to the house of the member of
a jewish militia who let them hide in
his apartment other times they hid for
days in partially flooded basements
isaac also helped build an escape tunnel
for jews to hide which they were able to
construct without detection
in november 42 a forced labor camp was
established for the 1470
um jews who were working for the oil
company
in borislav and during that month isaac
was issued an r badge um identifying him
as a huston's abayta this was a very
life-saving document during the
interview he placed he had still has the
badge and he places it on his chest um
in this kind of in this kind of gesture
it was clear that this was an incredibly
important document for him that he kept
this pass allowed him to leave the camp
to conduct technical work for the oil
wells um he had to pay bribes to
officials um
issuing um another id card that
specified he was a specialized engineer
this profession obviously was important
for the war effort
um authorities continued to kill and
transport jews to concentration camps
and they completed the liquidation of
the borisov ghetto where they in june
43.
so in this last phase of um of the war
in april 44
as the germans were doing these final
completing these final liquidations and
the soviet army began advancing toward
boroslav isaac believed that the germans
would kill the remaining jews so he
forged to pass another document for his
wife and they were able to escape the
camp and for six weeks they hid in the
attic of a ukrainian peasant
alongside 16 other people borislav was
liberated by the soviet army on august
7th after liberation isaac was able to
acquire polish papers for louise and
himself and they were permitted to cross
the border into poland they went back to
libov where isaac's family had been
forced from the levoth ghetto into the
yanovska street camp and his family was
probably killed there in 1943 when the
ghetto and the camp were destroyed in
the city was declared free of jews
the couple then traveled to munich where
isaac acquired a job with the world wars
union um as the director of the
vocational
school there with 2 000 students
he provided training courses to
survivors to help them rebuild their
lives in new countries and in 1947 isaac
and luiz gave deficits for the court
proceedings against
the police and gestapo and borislav and
jerhobich
isaac and louise lived in munich until
emigrating to the united states in
october 1949 where they when they
changed their names to eric and louise
and settled in new york
here's an image of the oil fields in
borislav where they worked i'm sorry
this is a bit blurry this was the
orphanage he mentions in his testimony
so
um
let me tell you a little bit about my
selection process and and and here's the
document that he his testimony that he
gave i mentioned um in munich um to the
off at the office of liberated jews in
1947 which was held in the um sterling
memorial part of the collection of the
fortunate archive there that i was able
to to study as well um
well i started out looking at survivors
of wartime ukraine today's borders
because i worked on ukraine and i
thought that would be a good foundation
and then i um and i looked at those the
ones that actually were in english this
testimony um hauser gave in english
and his testimony really was outstanding
for me because of the vivid uh memories
that he presented um the image i
described to you of the german planes um
firing into the trains um the fact that
he he was able to provide that kind of
empirically rich detail specific names
and places of people he interacted with
the poles ukrainians russians germans
and fellow jews
um identifying the worst perpetrators in
the region i i and many of those names
were familiar to me and i knew some of
them were very obscure um not that well
known in the literature and yet he was
calling them out uh for um like um one
of the chiefs chiefs i wrote about in
hitler's furies actually is the husband
and wife and andre hobish the blocks
um also he had this supporting
documentation this testimony that's on
the screener from 1947 which you know
would open up another um
possibilities for research to kind of
corroborate those names and to look into
those uh war crimes cases
his uh the fact that he covered kind of
each chapter of his life his youth in
poland um he described the inner ethnic
tensions of poles and ukrainians and
jews and how that was aggravated and
exploited by the soviet and nazi
occupiers
he was candid about some of the most
cruel and shameful behavior including um
crimes committed by jews uh sexual
violence there's you know he just
um there were no taboos in the way that
he um presented his his
account um and the clarity of his
purpose he said i'm giving my testimony
and or he would stop and kind of cue the
audience you know
um pay attention to this you know
um but also the fact that you know he
was not
um
in his straightforward
um
accounts you know he there were a lot of
it was very emotional as well and he
would stop uh the kinds of gestures on
the screen the the pauses the coughs um
the downward glances sometimes he holds
up the paper and kind of hides behind
the paper as he's talking because he's
getting um uh
uh his eyes are welling up and when he
what he says moments when he becomes
overcome
um and the themes that are in his
storytelling of gender the sexual
violence the attention to women's
history the attention to class talking
about what he calls the klondike
laborers and the oil fields that he
managed the drill masters the welders
the blacksmiths the rough types he said
who were eager to fight whom the
russians broke and turned into ants and
lambs and informers
um his descriptions of race and the
hierarchies uh the nazi ladder they
talked of related privileges and
deprivations that were determined by
race
so my process of of going through
his his
testimony was
you know
multi-pronged in a way
first i listened to it um you know that
was stopping and
taking notes put inserting footnotes um
and various annotations and then i would
put my own remarks in about his manners
and his gestures and facial expressions
i basically combined the christopher
browning approach of triangulation of
testimony with other sources and various
tests of say probability and veracity
and logic i checked
his
stories and some of his the names and
places and accounts against um
secondary literature um dieter pohl's
work thomas john cooler tim snyder's
work uh uh kaisruva
um mick john paul himka of course then i
checked the
trial records for the perpetrators that
he identified
and
many of them
were indicted
in a case in framin and also an
important case that's uh occurred in
austria um waiting to get that
indictment actually from the vienna
library um i went into the its records
and found his name on various lists um
from the world jewish congress
um
yeah i
also tried to find his descendants i i
tried to i found the hauser family in
new york but it was buffalo new york not
rego park i found the wrong hauser
family another family of uh the
descendants of survivors um i talked to
actually yesterday in buffalo new york
but not the right one um so i'm trying
to uh pursue that as well
so i combined this empirical approach
with what kind of known schenker and
hank greenspan stress in their work on
listening and reframing holocaust
testimony with special attention on the
performative aspects because of course
this is a video account
and i was inspired as well by what the
founders of the fortunate archive
envisioned um that is a collection of
voices that effectively
effectively and
effectively um created a provisional
community bound by memory and the
recognition of trauma so i wanted to be
conscious of the manner in which the
testimonies were collected the stories
uh how they are told of of human
suffering and then the history that is
then um created as a result or conveyed
and and received
in noah tunker's book reframing
holocaust testimony makes an interesting
distinct distinction between
uh or among chronologically charted
testimonies
on the one hand the redemptive cathartic
version a kind of dialectic with the
interviewer
and then um the third what uh he refers
to as these
testimonies that that contain
um in langer's words frozen moments of
anguish and this is what hauser called
in his own self-effacing way moments
when he stated at the end of his
interview quote i cannot collect myself
sometimes so well one is overcome
so i was interested in this um on a more
conceptual side the storytelling that
the ruptures the unsettled moments not
the usual digressions that we talk about
um in history writing but as schenker
states those both shattering and
unifying impulses
so why did um
our subject uh isaac hauser why did he
um
testify uh first of all the pursuit of
justice here i've had this slide up for
a while um the list of names was rather
astounding you can if you can read this
german document it's also an english um
translation of of of the killers and
distinguishing between the gestapo and
the shubo and um had you know was had
really um uh had retained that
information and deliberately during the
war um documented that and then
immediately went or you know went to the
um liberated jews commission in munich
to to
provide that information
um secondly um he stated the reason i do
this interview only i would like to show
that the russians
broke our spirit
in a way
there well the germans killed us
physically so there are a couple of
occasions where he compares the germans
and the russians
um and of course in this
period in the literature
especially to make the snyder's work
among others of this notion and the
politicization of the double occupation
or the entanglement of the soviet um
nazi systems and it's in his testimony
it became clear to me that this
entanglement is that that kind of
characterization is maybe not entirely
correct and certainly not this notion of
a binary of a double occupation that can
be compared as worse
um or better both qualitatively or
quantitatively but instead um eric isaac
um he describes
what he calls the kind of russian cure
um and describe it very quickly in a
moment um as um
part of the the radicalization um uh and
i guess snyder would go back to 1933 to
show how this kind of
um occurs over time um but uh
the way that um the russians
treated the you know in his first phase
was so demoralizing um uh as he
describes it um
he says i'm quoting now
um
we didn't my reason for appearance today
is i wanted to make sure i don't know if
i did to stress the point that we should
have resisted much more strongly than we
did
we as in the jews and we didn't because
the russians have conditioned it to us
the russians with their preceding
occupation have changed us into a bunch
of low animals i don't know probably
lower than rats because i read that when
rats are pushed towards the wall they
will rear up their legs and they will
show their teeth and they will try to
bite
the russians have methods and the best
proof is right in the russian history of
the last 40 years
the germans were murderous this is all
well known there's no secret to it the
russian ruler calamity um uh is not as
well known they didn't they didn't
liberate us we survived because of some
skill of some good luck of some happy
coincidence i hope the i think the
russians helped kill us my father was a
very strong man he was a building
contractor but they wrote they broke his
spirit they came in he wasn't permitted
they came into our house he took her
house every night they came to try to
arrest him every night he slept on the
roof because he he wouldn't go up on the
roof to look um
just describing this incredibly
demoralizing uh
period uh preceding the german german
occupation that ultimately
created this situation um frozen moments
of anguish according langer here and in
hauser's reflections about the fate of
his family um
here he he describes how his father uh
at the moment of the onset of the war in
39 with the bombs falling that his
father just became so focused on his
work that was his
uh identity that was his his dignity um
he says my father was building a huge
house for poland it was a huge house a
four-story house in the city of lemberg
he finished building it as the first
bombs were falling in lemberg in 1939.
what is interesting for my father that
he paid his debts he was convinced his
worth is as good
and then this is when he starts to get
choked up and he stops and he gets he
looks down he starts to scratch his chin
and then he kind of smiles a little bit
that his worth is as good
as gold while the bombs were falling he
paid his debts
and and then he describes how the
russians completely um broke the spirit
of his father um but there's there's a
kind of critique of his father's
reaction um to the war and the first
bombs falling um and a kind of irony
there as far as his continue wanting to
focus on work and not realizing the
gravity um of this situation
and then secondly when um
eric is fleeing with um with his wife to
borislav when they realize they need to
get out of levov
he runs back during the pogrom and his
family is sitting together including his
sister and his brother's younger sister
and brother and he says i went in my
family was there i told them disperse
there was something vicious going on and
they said no we sit together we feel
better when we sit together and so they
sat together they all died together i
ran away and i hid out
and so is this um kind of frustration
that he seems to communicate about not
being able to rescue us you know save
his family and convince them to to leave
and he doesn't see them again after that
um and he assumes that they died in
yanovska and i'm gonna show you uh how
that kind of follows through into the
rest of his biography um not knowing
kind of their their ultimate fate really
i mean what happened what happened to
them after um he left um in those
intervening years
um i don't know if i have that much time
how much time do i have left
um we're a little bit over time so if
you can just okay then i'm gonna then
i'm gonna skip through this um i just
want to point out here we can't read all
this um the other element of the
testimony having to do with the memory
of the senses and being attuned to
um uh expressions of
of set of sound of sight of smell the
fact that he describes here um in his uh
one of his intentions was to to show the
total brutalization that occurred so he
has vivid descriptions of the of the
violence um and here's a german official
uh who is um
kills this jewish boy
um 12 to 13 year old boy uh who's
already wounded and the ss man says oh
it's some there's a discussion should we
leave this child in peace um the kid is
afraid and then the more brutal german
says zola learning cried the first one
he should learn now that is something he
should learn
um
learning and then isaac hauser says it
sounds in my ears and they um they kind
of finish off that child um and a
similar kind of
uh way of storytelling races i have to
say i saw this i saw this and that's the
other account on the right that has to
do with the sexual violence the rape of
a jewish woman in his office by a jewish
co-worker
these are uh snapshots here are still
screenshots of the documents that he
presents during his interview that i uh
wanted to pay attention to
and then lastly this is a prisoner bowl
that he um brought to the holocaust
museum so i checked where eric hauser
might have donated things or given
testimony at other institutions this was
given in 1990 after after his 1985
testimony why he didn't have the bowl at
this you know at this moment um but his
papers is a question um i thought was
interesting but he ended up donating
this bowl it's a bowl he found when he
went to the anovska camp in search of
his family um there's no it didn't you
know belong to his family it's kind of
symbolic it's what he has left of his
family
um so my concluding questions have to do
with the critical edition and how do i
bring this all together as far as both
the performative um the kind of sensory
aspects of his uh storytelling and the
deep memory um and then the
contextualization of that as a story and
the more empirical uh side of that and
how far do i go with that um without
kind of diminishing his um story or do i
fill in his gaps of memory um and how
far do i go with that in my introduction
and my annotation and i open that end
with that and i invite your questions i
welcome them i'm looking forward to your
reactions thank you very much
thank you wendy um thank you so much for
um for talk um i'm going to present um
the next talk and then we'll take some
questions um at the end until please
feel free to write them in the q a
box um so our next speaker is jonathan
metropolis
who is the john v cruel professor of
european history at claremont mechanic
college in southern california
between 2000 between 1998 and 2000 dr
metropolis professor metropolis served
as research director for art and
cultural property on the presidential
commission on holocaust assets in the
united states where he helped draft the
report restitution plunder the u.s and
holocaust victims assets
um he also provided expert testimony to
the sect committee on cultural media uh
cultural media and sports in the uk
house of commons and to the banking and
finance committee of the u.s house of
representatives regarding his issues
he's the author of multiple books which
you can read about on his profile page
and our website among the most recently
uh growing his men in paris the story of
a nazi art plunderer and his world uh
which was published by eon university
press um and i'll um let you speak
thank you gail for that very gracious uh
introduction and thanks to steven neron
and timothy snyder uh christy bailey
thomacheck and all the the folks at the
fortune off video um testimony archive
um it's been a it was a wonderful
semester on sabbatical such an honor um
so i'm going to talk about sidney
bruskin and i would mention um i
selected him because of my next project
i'm writing a book along with wendy
lauer about 1945
and
war's end and what happens to some of
the nazi leaders and
and sydney bruskin's story fit into that
that project i had considered doing a
testimony involving nazi looted art in
my specialty but i found that bruskin's
testimony was very rich and took me in a
direction i wanted to go so ruskin is an
interesting figure he's a son of jewish
immigrants he's a new haven lad
a yale graduate
a member of the counter-intelligence
corps that arrested french collaborators
and nazi war criminals he was a
liberator of a concentration camp and a
person whose wartime experiences shaped
his faith and his identity
bruskin was interviewed in 1994
which was rather early for interviewing
veterans saving private ryan the film
came along in 1998 and that led to a
kind of collective project to interview
the greatest generation
congress uh passed a bill starting uh
interview federal project interview
veterans and in the first 10 years they
interviewed over 65
um but ruskins is earlier and uh but it
does fit into that trope of
of uh veterans interviews um and i
should also mention that i found in the
yale university archives uh an interview
that bruskin did nine years later in
2003 as part of a new haven oral history
project and he was interviewed by a
local high school student and reflected
on his years growing up in new haven and
that was useful for the first part of
the annotation um so as i mentioned
bruskin was the son of immigrants uh his
father and mother arrived in 1907 and
1909 respectively from russia and his
father was a barber his mother was a
dressmaker and and so bruskin is part of
a broader immigration process or pattern
you know between 1881 and 1914 over 1.5
million russian jews fled persecution in
zara's russia
as you probably know that there were
pogroms in the early 1880s and then
between 1903 and 1906 and scholars say
generally that the early programs didn't
precipitate so much immigration but the
1903-1906 ones did and there's one
scholar yanai spitzer who wrote jewish
migration from the russian empire to the
united states in the years 1881 to 1914
was one of the most intense mass
population movements in history over a
single generation more than a quarter of
jewish russian of the jewish russian
population was resettled oversea
sees the russian empire was home to some
5.3 million jews in 1897 approximately
half of world's jewry so i think to see
ruskin as part of that process was for
me rather rather interesting
also um the let's see we get this the
the uh the assimilation in new haven and
what it said about the the local history
of new haven was to be very interesting
as many of you know in new haven it was
called copper city because of the
important uh trades and heavy machinery
and manufacturing and so you see these
immigrants coming in uh as part of the
industrial revolution and so this the
story of assimilation to me was was
quite interesting uh bruskin went to
hill house high school still there but
it's changed his demographic markedly um
and he he was raised in a very secular
uh jewish family and i'll talk about
that a little bit more towards the end
of my presentation um very smart very
clever and he was admitted to yale and
he matriculated from 1932 to 1936 and of
course this was a period with numerous
clauses right in 1935 yale accepted 76
applicants from a pool of 501 about 200
of those applicants were jewish five got
in right
and there was a quote from a dean at the
time d milton winterheitz and he said
never admit more than five jews take
only two italian catholics and take no
blacks at all
and this did this continued through the
1960s
this is quite well known uh there was a
limit a quota of about 10 percent um dan
oren a 1979 yale a graduate wrote a book
that's
been well recognized joining the club
and and so
sydney bruskin you know embodied this
right he he actually lived at home um uh
jews and christians at uh yale were
segregated until 1948
and he didn't have enough money to to
live on campus so he lived at home and
he was socially isolated in this way and
it was very interesting what you know
his experiences there i love the story
the first time he had a ham sandwich i
was teased into it because i wasn't
supposed to but i could see some of the
guys were some of the jewish boys were
eating ham sandwiches so i said all
right here goes i took it and i said oh
boy i'm probably going to drop dead but
i survived
but more important with you know less
levity uh he noted we jewish boys
accepted the fact that there was a sort
of we were sort of outcasts not exactly
outcasts but we were at the uh at the
edge we accepted that and we didn't do
anything about it we didn't protest
so um bruskin at yale he mentored and
majored in french languages uh french
and other romance languages italian he
had some german he learned some yiddish
later on and i found this to be very
interesting interesting it reminded me
of what george steiner said uh george
steiner was born in 1929 to viennese
parents who had left austria and gone to
paris and his father
who had raised the family the children
multilingual said that he believed jews
were endangered guests wherever they
went and equipped his children with
languages in the steiner household it
was german french and english but you
know it wasn't clear with bruskin if
this was one of the things he was
thinking about that this would be
helpful but he loved these languages and
it proved
important in his subsequent and
subsequent developments
when he graduated in 1936 he didn't have
good job prospects in the depression but
uh through complicated circumstances he
stumbled into a bike business um
interesting he could not even ride a
bike and i wondered about that why he
couldn't um but he was able to open a
shop on chapel street and um i went to
look for the for the shop his bicycle
shop and i couldn't find it and a little
bit more research i realized what had
happened it was torn down in 1961 and it
was replaced by the uh the school the
yale school of architecture um that
controversial building that brutalist
architecture uh architectural historian
elizabeth mills brown and had said this
building has probably caused more fury
than any other american architectural
work of the mid 20th century a storm
center from the start praised as the
prophet of a new architecture damned as
willful and egocentric dogged by
misadventure victim of arson student
vandalism remodeling an endless
complaint the a a building has a bitter
and embattled career so
that's what happened to sydney bruskin's
bike shop um he had married and uh and
so he was not immediately drafted and i
talked a little bit about the about
conscription the first peacetime
conscription in american history in 1940
uh he had a daughter uh and that also
delayed his induction into the military
but by 1943 he was he was
drafted
went through basic training in
camp shelby fort shelby down in
mississippi and then at fort devon's up
in massachusetts and then he was shipped
to england
not knowing exactly what he was going to
do
and here is sydney bruskin as a private
shortly after uh finishing um basic
training and such and in the uk uh the
counterintelligence corps was looking
for individuals with language skills um
there was a dire shortage of individuals
who could speak european languages and
so bruxican had his opportunity with his
language skills and so he became a
member of the counterintelligence corps
of the 80th division and he started well
he he arrived at uh in france on d-day
plus 30 at omaha beach right so one
month after a d-day in in early july 19
1944
and he was in his cohort were given
lists of nazi uh officials and their job
was to go search for them and the the
lists were published after the war and
when i was writing in gurian's man in
paris about bruno loza this was part of
the list just to give a sense they had a
thick volume of high-ranking nazis
including the orts group and lighter the
local officials and and they would go
pursue uh pursue the nazis they started
off actually with french collaborators
um and that was kind of a training for
bruskin as he would learn to interrogate
informants and to to work with local
resistance and to apply his trade but he
really became much more aggressive when
they went into germany and austria later
on and and probably the high point for
bruskin certainly was a high point in
terms of hunting for nazis was an al
taozay uh a small town in the salts
commerce
and i spent quite a bit of time in al
jose myself it's really right where the
u.s zone is here it's not too far from
salzburg but it's in the middle of the
austrian alps there and al jose had been
a repository for uh artworks including
hitler's collection over 4 500 pictures
in in the fewer museum were there and
many other looted works there had been
drama there at war's end as the local
gaul lighter igruber had ordered bombs
to be placed in the entrance to the mine
and it took an act of resistance the
local miners to to to pull them out and
diffuse the bombs and uh here they are
with some american uh soldiers who
who've come in the first to arrive uh
and of course there was a long process
of evacuating the mines in the
monumentsmen film they do it in one
afternoon and in fact it took them four
months to do so
the roads were impassable um so in alf
jose though besides looted artworks one
found an array of high-ranking nazis
from aaron's calton bruner to adolf
eichmann to otto scorceney
august high group where the gall lighter
was there hugo jury franchitango was
there the sobibor treblinka cam
commander anton berger the head of tr
you get the point it was just filthy
with nazis and so that's where where
bruskin and his partner robert matson
arrived and i should also mention i had
gone and found old nazis in altau's a2
in the 1990s and early 2000s i had
interviewed wilhelm hotel
and some others there so
it's still a place that has a brown past
if you will um so bruskin he played a
key role in arresting igruber the gal
lighter and specifically igruber's wife
that was bruskin alone
but
and this is this is this is bruskin and
his interview uh to the left i know it's
very blurry as a screenshot but um gives
you a sense how they they were just
finding uh local facilities and turning
them into prisons and arresting these
these people um the highlight of his uh
you know activity and hunting for nazis
was arresting aaron's carlton bruner uh
the head of the reich security main
office and carlton bruner had a villa
there i mentioned earlier it was filled
with treasure over 60 kilos of gold was
found there most of it disappeared but
he took flight as the americans arrived
and he went into the deep wilderness
there up into the alps and uh and
reports came in that that carlton bruner
was probably up there in in the in the
hinterlands and so
robert matson uh bruskin's partner took
partner took the lead he was very
gung-ho if you will and he put on
austrian hunting gear attire he found
some local austrians who were had been
in the vermont but were now prepared to
help and along with some american gis
they hiked all night for seven hours
over snow and ice and found caltran
bruner and his adjutant major scheidel
uh in this this hut there and uh it was
a very tense standoff but they managed
to arrest calton bruner without without
firing shots he claimed to be a
physician and to be someone else uh
bruskin was back with carlton bruner's
mistress uh an aristocrat uh who had
just given birth to twins carlton
bruner's twins and uh and
uh scheidel's wife was also there so
when they marched these two people back
into al talizay and bruskin had the
women there he was keeping them under
under guard they ran to their to their
romantic partners and they embraced them
so that was the form of identification
with the with the women showing who they
actually were and it was interesting how
how this was such a high point in
bruskin's career for matson too uh he
wrote a book about arresting carlton
bruner and would lecture and and uh they
they they they kept souvenirs if you
will trophies from their experience
matson kept the identity badge of colton
bruner and arthur scheidler's went to
bruskin which he still had and he was
holding up as a symbol he also brought
back scheidler's rifle which he sold in
the 1990s for four hundred dollars and
that was kind of interesting in his way
um
also besides arresting carlton bruner
and igruber and some of these others um
bruskin went to abense right and this is
a photo that he took upon arrival and uh
is a sub camp of mott hausen uh it it
really uh
came into existence uh about halfway
through the war um in 1943 it held about
28 000 male inmates and about 11 000 of
them had died in the camp and
brusca's testimony is interesting here
right he says on our way bob matson
picked me up in campton bavaria actually
bought in vortenberg but and we were
going on our down to to alse on the way
we had heard that there was a
concentration camp even say which was
not far from although so we drove there
when we got there there were bob wrote a
book and i have at home a sort of
pamphlet he claims that we broke the
lock to get in there i say definitely i
say that we were among the first troops
there i remember going through this gate
and there were a few soldiers there very
few so whether bob manson broke the gate
to get into abe and say or not we're not
quite sure um but you know this was the
the the scene that bruskin and matson
encountered there uh you know as
liberators and there's some fascinating
accounts of um the liberation there as
the americans well subsequent to bruskin
and and and matson arriving the american
army arrived in panzers and they drove
in and the discussion was how the
americans were uh looking at the inmates
as if they came from a different planet
that they were hardly recognizable and
same with inmates looking at the
americans some of the inmates tried to
climb up on the panzers on the tanks and
the americans gently but firmly you know
pushed them down and said no we have to
keep away
they brought up one or two prisoners and
gave them lucky strikes and said tell us
what's going on here though a couple who
could speak english and they were you
know getting a sense of what happened um
there was an interesting episode when
they went found the kitchen uh there
that the cook there wanted to give the
american liberators
some of some food and serve them the
soup and the americans didn't want to do
so and they were told that it would be
rude not to accept this act of
generosity so they were given bowls and
they took a couple spoons of the of the
broth and of course they said it tasted
wretched it was terrible but this very
interesting moment of
encounter between the american
liberators and the camp inmates um quite
a few of them died from the refeeding
syndrome that i think you all know about
there so there's an interesting moment
with bruskin um as he as he uh
experiences this this concentration camp
um there was a crematorium there and
above the crematorium was this sign it
was a little poem about
the bodies wanting to be burned and
returning to nature and uh bruskin
ordered an inmate he said it was a cappo
who was tall and well-fed to tear to
bring down the sign and and he did and
bruskin carried the sign all the way
back uh to america and he put
this notation on his copy he donated the
originals to the u.s holocaust memorial
museum right but this was another
war trophy right the crematorium sign
that he that he brought back and i
thought that was interesting what he was
carrying all over europe for the next um
next six months um
eventually bruskin went to nuremberg and
he was part of the team of interpreters
that worked there
his german was not good enough for him
to be an interpreter for calton bruner
for a major war criminal but criminal
but he was part of the the broader
interrogation process and then uh came
home in late
1940 45 um
early on in the nurnberg trials um this
was another uh
photograph that he made in a jewish
cemetery and he kept this is himself
there and one thing that i found was
really striking about this testimony um
well i'll let this this um quotation
here right uh
but it changed my whole outlook going to
europe and hunting nazis and liberating
abense on everything i had never had
much of a jewish upbringing we never
belonged to a synagogue i didn't have a
bar mitzvah and so forth but that
changed completely no no i went back to
my roots after seeing particularly the
the camp and the women in ludwig's
hospital and so forth he had seen
victims and lose the coffin on lake
constance as well when i came back i
decided that i was going to become a jew
boy again i didn't know how to start and
then i got a letter from the lodge bene
brit invited me to a breakfast and any
group that approached me at that point
they were going to get me i signed up
right away because i figured this way i
could identify myself as jewish
and with sydney bruskin and looking for
what happened to him after the war he
shows up in the new haven in the hampden
jewish communities and he's he's
participated in dinners and other kind
of
community events and such and and wendy
and i we went and found sidney bruskin's
grave gravestone his last resting place
in the michigan israel cemetery there
right so it was interesting to see uh
someone who would focus so much early on
in assimilation and being an american
and um you know going to yale and then
you know the experience of the war um
which shaped him so so so profoundly so
um so yes so um
mine is still very much a work in
progress um i had hope also hope to find
uh relatives of sydney bruskin and i was
calling bruskins around the country we
can see from this gravestone behind that
he has children and grandchildren but i
have yet to to find them so
i'm going to continue to work on my
testimony in the coming weeks and coming
months it'll be done this summer um but
hopefully i can find some family members
and get that perspective as well so
thank you for your attention i
appreciate it
thank you so much um fascinating talk
and for fascinating um two talks here
i'm gonna start actually reading out um
the first question and please um
um everyone please write to us um with
your uh questions for um
uh professor lauer and professor
petropolis um so loris lawrence langer
asked um writes here for the sake of
accuracy memory of the senses is
charlotte delbo's language which i
borrowed my question to wendy is is
anything lost from the impact of the
personal ordeal of the survivor by such
extensive contextualization this is a
question from a non-historian not a
criticism
well i think you know i'd be curious to
hear from others on this as well um on
how to think about
you know
is there a balance to be uh achieved or
aware of um
it just it just struck me as i was
embarking on the critical edition and
looking at the typical kinds of
introductions and i introduced a diary
that i published uh years ago as well
the as an historian you know i have this
um compulsion i have this uh uh
routine of as well of of
trying to you know check the facts and
and fill out the history and and tell
the story of the holocaust in borislav
and tell the story of the holocaust and
galicia um but that kind of adding that
kind of apparatus that kind of um either
however you want to put it grounding or
or introduction you know at what point
does that then diminish the the power of
the story of of the survivor um you know
as you put it the the impact of that
because that's the subjectivity of that
and the
and those um frozen moments of anguish
for instance um in themselves are so so
revealing so i that's i don't have
really a direct answer to your question
because as i concluded you know um how
do we deal with annotation and kind of
traumatic autobiographies that contain
these ruptures and unsettled moments do
we fill in those gaps um
you know do we add layers of
do we add to the layers of personal
memory another layer of official history
um and you know how much is is
useful um uh and and illuminating and
supportive of
um of that testimony of that survivors
um not diminishing that survivor's voice
so i mean i'd like to hear from gil and
some of the other participants on this
issue if they've thought about it in any
way
great um yeah so i'm gonna actually tie
this to maybe something um if people
want to ask any additional questions
here um but i wondered if um you want to
tell us a little bit about um a question
i received uh for jonathan um also
somebody just wrote me but um if um if
you're gonna maybe kind of discuss this
and kind of discuss um also your
previous work on gluted art um in
relation to this and just see just a
question about um how does this relate
to um fortune off testimonies and you
can
see if any of the fortnight there's
anything add to that in some way it's
one of the questions
so this is for me
yeah and i'll connect also to wendy's
question in a minute i'm sorry
so no i'm glad that um the question was
posed um because it goes back to the
process by which i arrived at sydney
bruskin and um you know i i looked
through the fortune off archives just
for looted art and any references of art
and it was striking how art
came up frequently uh as part of
people's lives and and some of the
individuals had been artists or they had
family members who were artists um they
had art collections and
and um
what i what i took away from reading
those testimonies was something i had
sensed before and and and you know read
about before but it was really palpable
in the testimonies is how art is
uh
different from most kinds of assets and
that it's so personal um it's such a
part of people's lives and and and so
you know people live with artworks and
proximity they're passed down from
generation to generation and and so i
did see um that come to life as people
talked about family portraits that were
missing and collections that had
disappeared and and so to see that uh
animated and such was was striking um
you know with with sydney bruskin um
you know the objects that he brought
back and the way he treated them and i
think wendy talked about these too what
would house her kept you know they had a
kind of a special power they were
talismans and the fact that he had held
onto major scheidel's identification
badge for 50 years was sort of you know
it was interesting and and i think
representative but but it was almost
there you know bruskin sensed the kind
of evilness that was there and and this
was almost something magical that he had
you know he that he wasn't going to
protect him but it had a certain aura to
it and equality and he was fascinated
with it so i think this notion about
objects and auras
is really really interesting to me and
connects both the nazi memorabilia
objects and the the looted artwork the
artwork that people lived with
and um back to um what when wendy said
um and i'll maybe open it also um if you
have other questions but also the julian
chad i mean which i think it's a great
question i'm thinking about what does it
mean to is there all is there a risk
there of over contextualizing is there's
two extensive contextualizing what does
that mean um for the personal experience
of the survivor um right because we use
the the the contextualization so to put
the survivor in a different story um
than the one that he or she may be
wanting to tell um so i'm wondering also
if this is something that um
chad and julie or jonathan you also want
to address um how that um kind of that
tension
is something that you might think about
or deal with in the way you're
approaching testimonies
i don't know how to answer this yet but
i think there's
there's one interesting book i read
recently um and reviewed
that uh
might offer some tips that eva nowak
mossa's
recently published memoir of the last
days of terezian stop
in that
it's it's a memoir that she wrote
you might think of it as a diary that
she wrote as as she was interested
and then she went back and tried to
mediate her own
diary and the press attempted to place
all of her her post-war editions all of
her
additions to the book that were not
contemporaneous they tried to put all of
those in in italics
um but if you go through it
with a fine-tooth comb you realize
there's a lot more mediation there than
they were able to cut in the italics and
it's kind of just
it's a fascinating book it's it's almost
like
uh it presupposes
these
edited testimonies right because it it's
it's the survivor doing it themselves
it's the individual who experienced this
trying to mediate their own early
testimony of those events
and
it's difficult to pick apart
uh really difficult to pick apart what
they knew at the time and what they
didn't but
um
fascinating in the attempt at least
when you raise an interesting point
about survivors themselves and
you know the the earlier
um
approach in in reading these and
listening to these testimonies was more
historical really i think um the fortune
off you know
made
huge strides in shifting attention to
the stories of suffering in of
themselves and to study the trauma to
study
listen to those voices you know
themselves and the subjectivity of them
um but then it's yes you have the other
phenomenon of the survivor who adds his
or her own contextualization and pulls
out history books while they're
narrating their own autobiography and
don't get it right all the time or
kind of it you know they don't tell us
their own personal stories they tell us
kind of what is kind of common common
memory versus their own
um
deeper memories so
it can happen both you know by scholars
as well as by the survivors themselves
yeah
i mean when when looking at a testimony
i'm reminded of something that one of my
professors actually in england said to
me um and he said historians you know we
engage in lumping and splitting and and
so with testimonies i you know clearly
we want something that's representative
and we can you know
gain insight into into uh
you know
events that affected many many more
people but we also want to do the
splitting and preserve what is unique in
the individual right and and to have a
voice and have an experience that's
that's exceptional so it's always that
balancing act and uh between
representativeness and uniqueness in
terms of the to the testimony
but just to add that in terms of
everything else that was said that i
very much agree with
sometimes the over contextualization is
done if it's not a survivor testimony
this is you're going to think this is a
kind of a strange comparison but
um
think about the fact that
the um
writings of perpetrators are often
heavily contextualized by scholars
because we you know we want to in a way
diminish the impact and
the resonance of that voice right so a
kind of
there's a decision that's made you know
kind of academic research decision
empirical
she dropped
oh we lost her
[Music]
yeah okay well just come in um yeah i
was just thinking about um
the name uh the name just um
escaped my mind which i shouldn't um but
you know the book um by another
professor here at yale about presley the
image of the genocide survivor
is the um stephen is probably going to
help me recover the name um and
historical image of the survivor of
genocide um as kind of a
general um right something represented
the general victim in the postwar period
looking um i forgot the name of the book
that's going to come back in a minute um
but um just generally how right that
experience has um has become kind of a
cultural experience rather than a unique
and personal experience i think this is
something that um
touched what wendy just said
i would i would also note that
the idea
behind the critical edition series is
not exclusively this
aimed at
sort of deep contextualization i mean
that's a part of the work the annotation
um
but uh it's also about
seeing a testimony through the eyes of
the individual scholar who is working
with it right to sort of um
and that's that's an understanding that
you know that's your this is your view
of the value significance um of this
testimony for historiographical
questions it's not the the only meaning
this this testimony has it's it's
through the eyes of you as
as the um as a scholar
um
and i would also note that
yeah um i i think this is a really this
is something that we we haven't
discussed enough it's still sort of new
for us um but
uh you know at in the end the the
original document the sort of frozen
moments of anguish etc are in the audio
visual recording
um and they're not um they're not uh i
think
uh
made less powerful by this this textual
contextualization right um it's another
layer but um i don't think it needs to
be seen as
uh a sort of a dangerous um layer that
could remove the power of the
subjectivity of the testimonies
that's my hope
yeah now it's just something to be aware
of
you know something to kind of just just
think about
um because there is this impulse
academically to
add the layers add the knowledge you
know do the empirical work especially on
the part of the historian and to really
kind of
um
you know present that in a way and kind
of show that office as advances in
knowledge right but the layering the
layering the layering
um
again that that potential exists there
that's all
you know and i'll also note that
another goal of the contextualization of
course is that the recognition of just
how complicated these documents can be
right and so um you know
trying to learn about the history of the
holocaust exclusively through survivor
testimony is a very difficult
if not impossible project so this
contextualization is really
ideally
there to to to help
provide um uh the kind of understanding
that might be lost if if if there was
not a scholar with you to help you guide
you through this complex document
um
at least
that's that's one of the goals
i agree i agree with you stephen i think
one of the things you get that you get
from reading the critical editions is
precisely looking at how a scholar uses
testimonies and what is the whole richer
world
that she or he brings um and they kind
of view the testimony um and it tries to
bring it just from you know story um
about the personal experience of someone
into a story that is tied so if you
highlight a certain place if you know
the place certain certain place was a
place in which um there was kind of
anti-jewish violence in the years
preceded that um or preceded the war you
could get a whole different
understanding
of the relation between you know the
the testimony and the and and and and
the context of it i think definitely one
of the things here is not it's not so
much a question of do we want is there
too much or too little of
context it's it's about showing how um
how can a contact center can can offer
one way to enrich your understanding of
this testimony
does
anyone else have do you have any more
questions um
from
the audience the participants um
it was very um
fascinating um
you know for talks very rich i can
understand that
people have a lot to um to think about
from four different um contexts and
perspectives
um
here
well i i wanted to say one thing i think
is really interesting about the
possibilities of the critical editions
in the
testimonies that i'm often using in my
research i'm trying to put back together
a cellular resistance organization so
by design not everyone knew about
everyone else
um
and i learn almost as much from what
they don't know is what they do know
and
were there to be a great candidate for
doing a critical addition
of a resistance like that you would
learn so much if you were the reader
going through looking at well here's
what
the witness knows
and here's what had to be filled in
alongside that and i'm just because of
where i'm coming from with my work i'm
really fascinated by the the chance to
look at those two things next to each
other
no i have to second that actually i'm
also thinking from the things that i
work on there's always a gap of
knowledge but the person you're writing
about knows only so much part of it is
because during the holocaust i mean
knowledge was so sporadic and putting
things together um is is a hard task um
some people's knowledge might be
confined to you know the period in which
she lives and doesn't know what's going
to happen next and we have that
foresight or that knowledge or just
because of the geographical location um
and so forth but i totally agree with
that
and one thing you'll see to
knowledge is
the inconsistencies that are um that can
be there uh sydney bruskin was asked by
the
interviewer several times
what he
knew about camps prior to entering into
abense and he completely contradicts
himself in the in the process at times
that we had no idea about camps and we
just sort of stumbled into them this one
and i would i had never imagined
anything like this and another time to
the testimony he said well yeah we heard
from our other gi's that there were
these kids and and just to realize that
that
is messy sometimes and that there is
contradiction
and we have to factor in that as we find
our
standards right so i think on um this
note um
i'm going to um to end this event and i
want to thank again all the speakers for
their wonderful talks and presentations
um and um
and i look forward to um reading some of
the critical editions that are going to
come out i think we all look forward to
reading some of the critical editions
that are going to come out from this
work um in the coming months um
and thank you everyone for um coming and
attending and listening to this event uh
stephen would you like to add anything
or no thanks thanks to everyone this is
great and thanks for our listeners for
for sticking with us to the
very end